can we see another car you have in there
this is my 55 Buick Roadmaster well I
came to Los Angeles newsstand I bought a
copy of the penny saver that's like at
one of the advertising you know people
have things for sale and I was looking
for a car from LA in a car before you
need a place to live because you can't
get to the place to live unless you have
a cop so I saw this advertised attorney
50 bucks and I bought it and I've had it
to 1972 I met my wife in this car we
dated in this car I took this got on my
first Tonight Show it's my last a night
show
I'll tell you a story my wife hates my
wife hates this story but it's kind of
funny because we had our first encounter
in this encounter on our 25th wedding
anniversary let's try and recreate that
so we both got the car and he drove to
where we had our encounter but now it's
a housing development so I'm like okay I
think it's right with that houses okay
let me pull up on the street okay and
the house is like right there so you're
not as agile at 25 with my hair and the
horns I see the fortune like come on the
guy comes running out what's going on
out here
but we had a lot of laughs and it's
pretty funny that's pretty much how
marriage goes oh right the second one
are different that's awesome I think you
have found the love of your life and you
can make out in the car I have made out
with my man in the car as well that's a
really cool car a car like yes this is
such a big car you don't even have a
radio you can just bring in live acts
just play right there with you yeah
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going